merci des trains en direct avec nous
c'est un mouvement de protestation
inédit en biélorussie alexandre
loukachenko et il en sursis écoutez
l'histoire est ouverte
donc il est difficile de prévoir de
prévoir l'avenir ce qui est certain
c'est que de toute façon clairement les
les élections en biélorussie sont peu
parlé de ce corps qui ont été
extrêmement lisse et à il est évident
que loukachenko n'a sans doute pas
obtenu que 80% des voix bien entendu à
mais ce qui est intéressant est
important c'est de voir les choses dans
la dans la grande durée historique c'est
à dire qu'en fait il faut analyser la
biélorussie sur le sol stoppe sa
relation avec la russie je pense c'est
pour ça que les implications européenne
que vous venez de mentionner sont
importantes c'est parce que clairement
il ya une dynamique historique de
rapprochement entre non entre la russie
la biélorussie et les traités qui ont
été signés dans des fusions de l'état et
l'année dernière on a presque sans suite
et en fait des projets qui devraient à
partir de 2020 pour prendre prendre
arrivée qui sont des fusions une fusion
entre les deux pays sur le plan
énergétique douaniers fiscale etc
et c'est intéressant parce que cette
dynamique historique qui semble à ce
jour inévitable elle devrait arriver
elle est aujourd'hui freinée par le
cachalot ses opposants tiphaine of
baricco et autres sont des juges et des
candidats trop pro russe
donc ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir ça c'est qu'en fait aujourd'hui
loukachenko a fait sa campagne en
dénonçant un petit peu les inerties qui
devrait amener à une rapprochement
encore plus étroit voire une fusion de
la russie la biélorussie et il est pour
l'instant le principal opposant à cette
inertie deuxième manifestation mouvement
de contestation est représentatif de
l'ensemble de la population biélorusse
août et on a vu dans vos images qui a
beaucoup de jeunes dont de toute façon
c'est que s'est sans doute comme partout
c'est les jeunes qui vont qui ont le
plus l'énergie de manifester donc oui je
pense qu the seas a représenté une forme
de ras-le-bol c'est tout à fait ce mais
c'est tout à fait normal
vous avez quelqu'un que le pouvoir de
1994 l'usure politique elle frappe tous
les hommes politiques dans tous les pays
du monde il ya que l'admirent poutine
qui résiste un peu mais file au pouvoir
depuis moins longtemps
donc oui de toute façon ils sont un
ras-le-bol et sans doute certains coca
chaîne coiffer moins de 80 % et les
ti-cats nova fait beaucoup plus étonnant
ce qu'a fait beaucoup plus de la savoir
si loukachenko a gagné ou pas les
élections si c'est impossible j'imagine
mais de toute façon oui c'est un ce qui
se passait sans doute c'est nouveau et
c'est sans doute au révélateur
révélateur en fait d'un de d'un début de
changement peut-être dans la population
biélorusse reste à savoir qu'est ce que
ces changements vont amener dans l'est
dans les mauls années qui viennent mais
je pense se cache est important c'est
que je pense que ce que tout le monde
pense un petit peu à maida nos
comparatifs et l'ukraine la biélorussie
n'est pas l'ukraine ce n'est pas un pays
a aussi désordonnée aussi des structures
et c'est un pays très centralisé très
tenu le loukachenko a vraiment le
pouvoir aujourd'hui à monthey surtout on
peut le voir dans vos images la
biélorussie n'est pas un pays si pauvre
que ça c'est un pays dans lequel l'état
fonctionne à la police et ce tour de
force bien entendu mais pas seulement il
ya beaucoup de choses qui font sommier
un système médical en état il ya une
production industrielle on s'éteint
c'est un réel petit état en fait et ça
c'est quelque chose d'important qui à
mon avis le différencie nommément
l'ukraine est alors comment expliquer ce
soulèvement populaire
maintenant et notamment en faveur de
l'opposante à svetlana tirana scaglia
novice en politique qui s'est par
ailleurs réfugiés en lutte en lituanie
et on l'a appris ce matin tout à fait
écouter bain sans doute là la catalyse
est un des mécontentements mais elle a
catalysé différentes tendances son mari
en 2018 qui était le candidat initiale à
visiter l'ukraine et la rencontre et la
bad et des nationalistes orthodoxe russe
il a lui parlé de l'existence d'un monde
russes unifiée qui dépasse les
frontières de la russie
donc encore une fois il faut peut-être
pas la cataloguer comme une espèce
d'opposante à lukashenko européiste
c'est pascal et donc sans doute elle
arrive ça catalyser un pente population
viscéralement anti lukashenko un pan de
population qui est favorable à plus de
rapprochement avec la russie
et peut-être qu'elles attisent des
espoirs de dirigeants européens ou du
vin d'un pan de la société biélorusse
peut-être plus européistes et dans les
grandes villes et qui voudraient au
contraire se rapprocher l'europe
je pense qu'elle est un espèce de
d'éléments de fusion être catalyseur un
petit peu alors les manifestations on a
vu les images ont été violemment
réprimées par les forces policières
alexandre loukachenko évoque des
protestataires téléguidé depuis
l'étranger il a signifié qu'il n'aurait
je le cite ni perte de contrôle ni ko/s
qu'il faut s'attendre à une escalade des
violences comment est ce que vous voyez
l'évolution de la situation ces
prochains jours ces prochaines semaines
alors tout d'abord je pense que
effectivement lukashenko elle pouvoir je
pense que les manifestions vont être
réprimés enfin on est sur des degré de
violence des volumes d'arrestations qui
sont infimes par rapport à par exemple
ce que la france a connu avec les gilet
jaune ou les la violence policière était
book bien plus importante
on est sur des volumes de violence bien
plus faible que ce qui se passe
actuellement aux etats-unis où je pense
qu'il faut il faut pas mais il ne faut
pas imaginer que c'est si grave que ça
mais il y avait déjà un peu moins de
monde visiblement hier soir
qu'avant-hier j'imagine que le maïdan
aujourd'hui n'est pas un scénario
possible pour la biélorussie parce que
l'état est très verticale que
loukachenko les sucres de fort son
pouvoir et je pense que les biélorusses
ne sont pas les ukrainiens et que
l'implication de quoi dire de structures
étrangères qui aurait intérêt ce que la
situation dégénère n'est pas aussi
importante en biélorussie qu'elle ne
l'était en ukraine et de toute façon si
la situation devait générer ce devait
dégénérer ça accélérait encore le
rapprochement entre la russie et la
biélorussie
par conséquent je suis pas sûr qu'on
assiste à une aggravation de la
situation
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous et
alexandre al aqsa entrepreneurs
analystes en relations internationales